this episode of the minimalists is
brought to you by nobody
because advertisements suck enjoy the
show 100% soy gluten and advertisement
free
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed you know I bet that
you'll be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to a special
episode of the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less actually I say
special but it's actually less special
than most of our episodes and here's why
I am solo today I'm sorry about that I
was actually supposed to be with my
partner in crime
Ryan Nicodemus we're both supposed to be
in st. Petersburg a Florida right now
which is where I'd love to be in the Sun
recording this podcast for all of you
but instead I my flight got canceled and
so I'm spending the holidays in Missoula
Montana and making the best of the snow
and the cold temperatures so I am solo
today and I figured you know if I'm
going to be solo and record a podcast
anyway maybe we could record a podcast
episode about something that only I
would have some insight on so I was
digging through the crates we have we
have many many crates of voice mails
Sean I don't know why you keep all of
our voice mail and crates minimalist no
we we have a lot of voicemails and we
had a few voicemails about parenting so
a while back Ryan and I have recorded an
episode about children I think it was
podcast episode number three and so this
will be this will augment that episode
you're welcome to go back and listen to
that and for all of our new listeners
welcome aboard we've had quite a few of
you join us over the last week or so and
so even if parenting isn't a topic that
is appealing to you now is the perfect
time to go back and listen to a lot of
our archives we have almost 50 episodes
of this podcast so well over fifty hours
of audio content for you to watch and
listen to for
you can go back and check out any of the
topics that are most appealing to you
whether it's technology we have an
entire episode on technology or finances
or debt or relationships and pretty much
everything in between a bunch of
different episodes out there for you to
go back download listen to the ones that
sound the most appealing to you but
today we're going to be talking about
parenting now I was actually going to
record this episode yesterday and Sean
had everything all set up to to record
this episode but I was wildly unprepared
and I realized that's actually probably
a bit of a metaphor for me and in
parenting right so for those of you who
are new to the show or are new to the
minimalists you'll know that I sort of
became a parent by proxy what almost two
years ago now I guess a year and a half
or so ago my partner Rebecca she has a
three year old daughter named Ella
and in fact Bex and I met because Ella
was flirting with me at the grocery
store so I was eating something over at
the good food store in Missoula Montana
and this cute little girl this cute
little 1 year old girl just kept waving
and flirting with me and her mother was
clearly embarrassed by the by the
behavior of this 1 year old and she's
kept waving and eventually I when I was
done eating I walked over and introduced
myself said hello and she said yeah I
know who you are and it was funny
because she had actually hired us to
speak at the the University where she
was working at the University of Montana
and somebody good conversation and and
and just started talking and I'll be
honest with you I never anticipated
never planned on having kids in fact
when people asked like do you plan on
having kids someday Lance was just
always know like right it wasn't it
wasn't in the cards for me and until it
was and and so since Beck's and I have
been in a relationship
chip I have become a parent and a father
figure to to Ella and so I have a friend
his name's Rob Bell and he talks about
he has three kids he lives on California
and a very prolific speaker but he talks
about with his kids all his kids are
still at home so he people often ask him
for parenting advice he has a podcast
and he's a former pastor and he although
we don't have the same sort of spiritual
beliefs or religious beliefs what what I
what I've learned from him is that we
have similar values and so one of the
things he talks about when people asked
him about parenting advice or asking
about his kids he says well my kids are
still at home he has two teenagers and
an older girl who is I believe eight
years old down and he said ah so I
because my kids were still at home I
don't have any parenting advice for you
but I have some observations and then
you know essentially he gives parenting
advice by proxy because he has a bunch
of really profound observations about
parenting and so me I have personally
learned a lot over the last couple years
about kids about parenting about being a
role model or a father figure and I
could tell you it's one of the most
difficult things to do and trying to
adjust to that but also so any of these
sort of observations that I have today
are not going to be my own observations
most of the time so I have good friends
like podcast Shaun here who has who has
three kids and two teenagers and a son
in his 20s and so I've got a ton of
advice from him and a bunch of my other
friends who have kids as well
and then of course I've read some
different stuff and I've I've listened
some to some different podcasts and
implemented different things over over
the last couple years from based on the
lessons that I've learned but just the
caveat I am still learning and I am
grossly unequipped to give you any good
advice on parenting but I will give you
my observations about this process and I
know we we have we have some
that I'm going to answer for you today
via voicemail and also the social media
so I think it's probably best to just
dig on in right now let's let's hop into
our voicemail questions from our
listeners our first voicemail is from
Rachel in Sacramento I have a daughter
she's 10 months old and so I don't know
if I'm just making excuses for myself or
if it really is that hard for everyone
but I at what point
like diapers cloth diapers I know one of
you has a child I'm not sure if the
other one does I want to reduce the
footprint I leave but I also want to
make things easier and minimalistic for
myself and for me the whole process of
cloth diapering seems overwhelming and
difficult are there other ways that i
can kind of start to live that
minimalist lifestyle with having a child
how do I pick into because I can't
obviously be you know packing up all of
my things like you guys did and then
unpack it little by little that's just
impossible being a single mom so I just
want to know what are some tips that I
can do with children to start getting us
to living that minimalist lifestyle
thanks for your question Rachel you know
you use the word there that I absolutely
hate and so let's start there and then
we'll get on to the good news right the
word you used is impossible I can't do
this and I think it's really important
to recognize the language that we use
either empowering or disempowering and
that's especially true I've noticed when
we have kids right because the language
we use around our kids is either going
to empower them or it's going to remove
the the power from that's going to
discourage them and the same is
obviously true for adults as well right
if as an adult you are you're using the
language that that something is
impossible you've instantly you cut off
the the the ability to grow at least in
that area and so when you say
you can't you know pack up everything
like Ryan did and so actually I you know
if when we talk about embracing
minimalism I didn't do the same thing as
Ryan we both had radically different
approaches in fact I think my approach
would probably be more more reasonable
for you but just because something's
reasonable doesn't mean it's the best
approach often being unreasonable is
going to be the best approach because
it's gonna allow you to make the most
radical change in your life but let's
talk about the two different
perspectives that Ryan and I have
so you mentioned Ryan's packing party
for those of you unfamiliar we'll put a
link to that in the show notes you can
find the details at the minimalists comm
slash packing you can also take a look
at his TEDx talk which is called a rich
life with less stuff he talks about that
packing party but the gist of it was he
realized that he had been working really
hard to buy all this stuff and he was
focused on maybe the wrong thing and so
he pretended he was moving he boxed up
literally everything he owned in his
2,000 square foot condo and over the
course of three weeks unpacked only the
items that he needed and at the end of
that experiment realized that all the
things that were supposed to make him
happy they weren't doing their job and
so he had 80% of his stuff 80% of his
stuff still in boxes and he decided to
donate or sell all of that stuff so that
he could get get it out of his way and
then figure out what was actually
important in his life right and so what
what he did was found a process that
worked for him to let go now he's a very
sort of type-a guy and and wants to get
fast results as many Americans do and
while I certainly wanted fast results
when I first started embracing
minimalism I realized that I had too
much of a emotional tie a sentimental
tie to many of the objects I owned and I
didn't even know where to get started
because the average American household
has 300,000 items in it I realized that
even if I got rid of 30,000 items it
would only be reducing my stuff by it by
10% but I knew I needed to start
somewhere I needed I knew I needed to
get some momentum so it took me about
eight months to radically simplify my
life and that meant starting somewhere
now for me I started with getting rid of
one item a day for 30
just to build up the practice of letting
go
eventually we turn that into something
called the 30-day minimalism game you
can get a count Abul with an
accountability partner and so that's the
first practical tip that I'm going to
give you a Rachel is is if a packing
party is too extreme for you by the way
anytime I think something is too extreme
for me I become interested in that
because what does that mean when we say
so I'm gonna go off on a tangent here
for a second but but when we say
something is too extreme for us but that
that tells me it's uncomfortable for me
and I try to lean into discomfort now
now why do I do that because I've
realized over the years whenever I put
myself in a place of discomfort not a
place of pain true pain or true
suffering but but a place in which I am
less comfortable than my day-to-day life
those are actually the places from which
I grow the most and certainly having a
10 month old daughter they're always
uncomfortable right kids are always in a
position of discomfort except they don't
see it as discomfort they see it as
opportunity and and they approach the
world with their eyes open and they're
constantly listening they're constantly
asking questions especially when they're
yelling I mean I can't see how many
times Ella every single day asks me why
why why why why and then when I give an
answer it tends to be it starts with the
word because and of course she starts
asking why because because she realize
she realizes that that there's a pattern
in my answers and so so when we are
exploring the world from a place of
discomfort that is usually the place
that we're going to learn the most so
whenever I say think something is
impossible or it's difficult or it is
uncomfortable I know that I should
probably lean into that a bit so I know
Rachel you say a packing party is not
the right thing for me but by saying
that then tells me that it might
actually be the right thing for you now
if it's just way too radical for you and
that's not the place for you to start
what about a packing party in one room
yeah or a closet or a bathroom could you
start there and could you figure out
what because what's the purpose of a
packing party it's it's trying to
determine what things I'm actually using
what things add value to my life and you
can ask that question for me it started
with that one thing a day for 30 days
but I had to ask the same question over
and over and over does this thing add
value to my life and by asking that
question repeatedly asking that question
over the course of about eight months I
realized that I became less of a
intellectual exercise asking you does
this widget that I own add value to my
life does this this toothbrush this
t-shirt does this couch does this
painting on the wall does this add value
to my life instead of asking that on an
intellectual level by asking that
question so many times it became this
visceral emotional response so I could
then look at things and just know
whether or not it was adding value to my
life and what I mean by that is does it
serve a purpose in my life is a tool of
some sort that augments my experience of
life or does it bring me joy in some way
and it could be music or artwork or or
something else that brings me joy and
the cool thing is minimalism is gonna
look different for each of us it's
certainly gonna look different for you
Rachel being in college and also having
a ten-month-old than someone who's maybe
my age 35 and I can tell you that seven
years ago when I was 28 years old my the
things that had a value to my life then
don't necessarily add value now so I'm
constantly asking that question does
this add value to my life well if you're
not gonna start with a packing party
although I would encourage you to maybe
try to lean into that a little bit then
maybe another another practical tip for
you is the 30-day minimalism game I'll
put a link to that in the show notes as
well over at the minimalists comm slash
podcast but the the minimalism game is a
great way for you to inject some
friendly competition into the mix and so
you want to partner up with a friend or
a family member or a co-worker and at
the beginning of a new month you decide
to start letting go of some stuff
together and here's how it works you get
whatever you want you can bet a dollar
or a meal or bragging rights or
or whatever you decide is a a winnable
and worthwhile prize at the end of this
little experiment and we found a way to
make this this decluttering a bit more
fun right because to me decluttering is
one of the most boring things that you
can do and so over the course of the
month you start out really simple right
you really easy actually on the first
day of the month you each get rid of one
item second day the month two items
third day of the month three items you
gives you that momentum you need to
start letting go and and also start
being a a role model in that sense for
for your child as well and and not just
saying here's what we're doing but
showing here's how I'm letting go and
letting go of attachment to these things
but as the month progresses with the
30-day minimalism game it becomes more
difficult day ten you're getting rid of
10 items day twelve twelve items day 17
17 items and so it progressively gets
more difficult now whoever goes the
longest throughout the month wins if you
both make it to the end of the month
then you've you've both won because
you've gotten rid of 500 items and I
think that's a pretty good start
and the cool thing about it is for me
when I let go of one item over the
course of 30 days one item a day over
over 30 days I ended up letting go of
way more than 30 items because once you
get that momentum embracing minimalism
gets easier by the day and it becomes a
sort of good addiction now realizing
though that getting rid of the stuff is
not the point I I think the stuff is
sort of the initial bite at the Apple
that changes everything for you by
clearing the clutter from life's path
then you start to be able to
reprioritize and focus on what's
important we also have have some rules
out there that will help you a couple
rules I'll recommend for you the 9090
rule have I used this item in the last
90 days and am I going to use it in in
the next 90 days now I was sitting down
with with my partner Beck's last night
we were going over these questions
together and one thing as an adult you
know many of the things that I have used
in the last night
days I I can I can say that quantifiably
but then I can all say yeah maybe I'll
use this in the next 90 days and so I
can give myself permission to hold on to
it but if not if I don't use it within
those next 90 days then I want to let go
of it but as a kid the kids grow out of
stuff within 90 days sometimes and so
that 90 90 rule can even be attenuated
sometimes for for kids is your gonna
know that six month old onesie that they
were they were wearing you four months
ago or whatever they're not going to
wear that any time in the future and so
you can donate that stuff that they're
no longer getting value from and it's
just sitting in a closet somewhere and
allow someone else to get value from
from those hand-me-down clothes and and
so the 9090 role has been beneficial for
me also the just-in-case rule or what we
call the 20/20 rule anything you're
holding on to just in case you can
typically replace for less than twenty
dollars in less than twenty minutes and
I think those are two good places to
start - two good boundaries for you two
to set up and when you're looking at
getting started Rachel I also think it's
important to understand the the benefits
of minimalism so ask yourself a question
how am I my life be better with less and
in your situation what is what does that
look like well you mentioned a few
things I might may be able to produce
less waste right because one of the
benefits of consuming less stuff is
you're just by definition going to
produce less waste and I think that's
great but also keep in mind it's not
about producing zero waste that
minimalism isn't necessarily a zero
waste lifestyle it's not binary it's not
all or nothing you're not going to
produce ten thousand pounds of waste a
year or zero waste a year
no it's about reducing your footprint as
you said and so I realized that you're
cognizant of the amount of waste the
diapers provide and if you can do cloth
diapers and you feel that that is time
well spent because cloth diapers are
going to be expensive for you but not
just monetarily but there's an initial
investment for sure but it takes up a
considerable amount of your time and by
the way I know Beck said this with with
Ella use cloth diapers throughout a
large portion of her first year on this
earth but used a a service because you
know didn't want to deal with with
cleaning out the the cloth diapers
herself and so she she used the service
to to clean up those diapers and that's
an additional cost or if you're gonna
clean it yourself that's an additional
cost of resources your time and most
important your attention how can you
better spend those resources as well
especially if you're in school and
you're trying to to earn a degree then
then maybe that's not the best use of
your time and attention and maybe the
best thing for you to do is reduce your
footprint in other areas and so by
consuming less overall you are going to
just by definition radically reduce the
amount of waste that you produce so keep
that in mind and realize that that the
amount of hassle that goes along with
the cloth diapers it may or may not be
worth it for you if it is worth it you
mean you have to be honest with yourself
you have to ask those questions and if
it's if it's not worth it though then
you want to look at reducing waste in in
other areas so that you can prioritize
your life because right now I I
understand that your life is probably
very busy you you're in a situation in
your life that there's a lot going on
but as their exes says busy is a sign
that your life is out of control and so
the busier that we get it just literally
and I don't mean that as I don't mean
that pejoratively but if we're so busy
it means we're probably in less control
than we want to be and so in order to
take back control we want to move from a
a lifestyle of busy to a prioritized
life of more focus and I wrote a lot
about the the transition of my life from
this very busy corporate executive I was
working 70 or 80 hours a week and I let
everyone else dictate my time and I was
busy busy busy all the time but I also
wasn't very focused in fact I forsook
the things most important to me because
my priorities were out of whack I gave
lip service to many of the priorities I
I thought that many of the things I said
were priorities my health of priority my
relationships or priority my writing is
a priority but truthfully our priorities
are how we spend our day we all have the
same 24 hours in a day and how we decide
to use those that those hours are really
what our priorities are so how you
however you spend your time those are
your true priorities and so I wrote a
lot about that journey and a book called
everything that remains it's my favorite
thing that that I have ever written in
fact if you've seen our documentary
which is called minimalism there's a
scene where I'm out in the the Salt
Flats in Utah reading an excerpt from
from from that book but Rachel I would
love to send you a copy of that book
either the print version or the eBook
version or we also have a audio book
version that's that's coming out really
soon so I'm sure we can get an audible
download code to send to her Sean if you
wouldn't mind sending her one of those
just reach out to Rachel and send her a
copy of that I think you'll find I think
you'll find some value in that Rachel
and hopefully some of those tips will
help you along the way as well our next
voicemail is from Ray in upstate New
York
from a family perspective I did look on
your website when it comes to family
suggestions and advice for downsizing
minimizing and I I saw some information
but I wanted to see if you could provide
a little bit more assistance in the area
of how to initiate it how to monitor it
and then to really be able to look back
and see what the results were right
you're certainly an analytical guy like
me yeah if I were to reframe your
question a little bit so from a I think
it's a three-part question really number
one is from a family perspective how do
you start minimizing as a family that
that's the first part of your question
and number two how do I monitor the
monitor the ongoing process and then
number three how do I measure our
progress or how do i how do i define
success would be maybe another way that
we could talk about that so first off
from a family perspective how do I start
minimizing
how do we start minimizing as a a family
well the first thing that I recommend is
is finding a common language so that you
can you can talk about minimalism in a
way that doesn't seem radical not right
I don't know how old your kids are but I
think for pretty much any age it you can
start to explain something with someone
as long as you have a similar language
to explain that thing I find it quite
often the term minimalism is the wrong
word to use up front because it's
off-putting to some people so we may use
some different isms you can say
intentional ism or just living
intentionally or being more deliberate
or be living more simply and these these
terms while they can be a bit more
nebulous they they can also I think
start to point people in the right
direction so if you're using a shared
language that's important so there a
couple ways to get some of this this
shared language first off right let me
send you I know you mentioned you tried
to go to our our screening in New York
City earlier this year and we didn't
have I guess it was it was sold out when
when Ryan and I did a tour stop there
with our documentary but I'd love to
send you a copy of the documentary it's
on Netflix now so if you have Netflix
you can check it out there but it's also
everywhere else and it's on Vimeo and
the reason I mentioned Vimeo I'm gonna
send you a Vimeo copy or Shawn if he if
he wants the DVD let's let's send him a
copy of the DVD if you're still watching
movies the old-school way we got you
covered right but I'd love to send you
the the Vimeo copy because or the Vimeo
link because there's six hours of bonus
footage there and I think you can die
view doesn't mean you have to watch it
all six hours there's something like 20
or 25 different videos you can dive deep
into the interviews that you really
liked from the film so the documentary
itself is about 80 minutes long but if
you find a particular interview that
really stands out to you like Joshua
Becker and his wife Kim and there are
two kids maybe you can dive a little bit
deeper into into their family story I
think that will help you out those six
hours of bonus interviews I think that
will help you establish some some common
language around simplifying that was
really the reason we put together the
documentary by the way is we wanted to
show people a bunch of different
perspective
on on minimalism not just the the Josh
and Ryan show we wanted to show you that
there are all these different
minimalists who are living appreciably
different lives but they attribute their
meaningful lives their happiness their
contentment and and their success in
life they attribute much of that to this
minimalist lifestyle and so I think
that's gonna help you get started using
the same language I think you also want
identify what the the benefits are so I
mentioned a moment ago when I was
talking to Rachel the question how might
your life be better with less asking
that question yourself helps you
identify with the benefits of minimalism
are for you
now that might mean finances or health
but helping your kids understand the
benefits are going to be somewhat
different for them and there's gonna be
a whole list of benefits so I would sit
down with your kids especially if
they're old enough and and have a family
meeting about how might our life be
better if we simplify it or how might
our life be better with less and at
first that's a jarring question what do
you mean how can my life be better with
less the American dream is to have more
more more and more stuff I want I want
more widgets and gadgets and the truth
is I want more too but I want more time
I want more experiences I want more
empowering relationships I want more
vitality more health more well-being I
certainly want more I just want more of
the important things and that's why the
subtitle of the documentary is a
documentary about the important things
when people ask you what minimalism is
all sometimes say minimalism is the
thing that gets us past the things so we
can make room for life's most important
things which actually aren't things at
all and that means that the important
things in our life are very rarely the
material possessions the material
possessions can't help improve our life
but quite often they can get in the way
and so identifying what the benefits are
what are the benefits gonna be for your
kids because they're different right the
having the decluttered closet is the end
result it is not the benefit for me
having declutter closet gives me it
makes me calmer for sure but but that
may not be the same benefit for a
teenage kid or a young kid so one of the
benefits going to be
for them and then as a family I would
identify what are our common benefits
because for you Ray
it may be getting out of debt is a big
benefit and I'm not sure if that's a
benefit for you or not but if it is then
that may not really resonate with your
kids and it's great that you're gonna be
excited about that but if they're not
excited about it and they don't have the
leverage that they need to let go and so
when you're talking to your kids about
minimalism you're really wanting to talk
to them about the benefits of oh way so
what does that look like for them what
does having a cleaner room mean for them
what is it having fewer but better
possessions mean for them and then I
think ultimately within the family you
can get some internal competition going
whether that's with that 30-day
minimalism game and having
accountability partners within the
household but also having people stay
accountable by having a donation box in
the house it's one thing that we have is
donation box but notice that even if
you're not forcing people to put things
in the donation box just knowing that
it's there that becomes contagious I've
had so many friends from my former life
back in the corporate world who have
talked to me about yeah we finally
started a donation box they thought I
was crazy when I was first becoming a
minimalist and I didn't try to impose my
brand of of minimalism on them they
started seeing the benefits and so they
wanted on board too and if you can if
you can really tap into those benefits
you'll see that you don't even have to
get them to ask and they'll start
putting things in the donation box
because they are gonna be mirroring you
they're not going it's gonna be much
harder for you to try to force them to
give away half of their things or
whatever they're not gonna be on board
with that but if they see the benefits
and they see that you're doing it and
you are personally experiencing some
benefits they're gonna start mirroring
you we all know that kids a mirror for
sure I mean I see this with with Ella
all the time and and I know that if if
I'm trying to explain something to her
the best way for me to explain something
to her is by doing the thing by having
her watch my behaviors and so yes I'm
often using
words but all the time the kids are
watching no matter what they are
watching what you do and they're
mirroring they're mirroring the good
they're mirroring the bad they're gonna
mirror the consumerism they're also
going to mirror the decluttering they're
gonna mirror the letting go I know Ellen
now often tries to donate stuff in fact
maybe a bit of it too much and and
because she has that that pattern bill
nighy she knows that we if we're not
getting value from something that we
that we donate it and we have a donation
box and when she doesn't want anything
anymore
even if she's angry and having a fit
show off and say I want to donate this
I'm gonna get rid of it and even to the
point where there's you know carrots on
her plate and she doesn't like them she
wants to donate the carrots and it's a
it's a learned behavior and she's
learning after us and the other thing
that I think is important with a family
especially as the kids get older to make
sure you're on the same page Beck's and
I are constantly having conversations to
make sure we're on the same page about
our relationship and about everything
that's going on in life and as Ella gets
older it's going to be important to me
to have to have monthly meetings and
discuss things like our finances and be
willing to be open about here's where we
are financially and here's what's
important to our life how do we define
success as a family because you you
mentioned earlier array how am I going
to measure the progress what really
depends on how you measure success right
and also realize that once you get
somewhere once you get to a success
point there's always gonna be a new
success point you know if success is
right on the horizon the cool thing and
sometimes the frustrating thing about
success is once you get to that horizon
there's what there's a new horizon
somewhere down there so you're
constantly aspiring to be the best
version of yourself and the best version
of your family together it doesn't mean
you're gonna be perfect the question is
what's the most ideal version and we're
striving to be that so me personally I'm
35 years old I'm striving to be my 36
year old self and then as a family was
my my 36 year old self look like as a as
a family unit as well
and so I'm constantly striving toward
that and but when I get there of course
there's gonna be a new more ideal
version to strive toward and so I take
the the lessons that I've learned the
the failures that I've had and by the
way I think it's okay to fail a lot
especially as a kid we have this weird
thing in our culture where we we
encourage our kids to only succeed and
it's gotten even worse over the last few
years we have partition participation
trophies you're succeeding even when
you're failing which actually I agree
with with that conceptually I agree that
you are succeeding when you're failing
but you you're succeeding because you're
learning from those failures I fail a
lot and it's the reason that that I'm
feel so successful in my life is because
I learn from those failures repeated
failure is a bit crazy if you're if
you're failing the same way over and
over and over again yeah that's that's
sort of the definition of insanity but
if we're learning from those failures
together especially as a family then I
think we can we can move forward and
have new successes and counting on those
those those those tiny successes each
month when you meet and you say okay how
did we fail this month what's our budget
look like this month how did we succeed
this month and how do we celebrate those
successes and also how do we celebrate
those those failures by learning from
them and carrying those lessons forward
there's also an essay that is in our
book essential so Shawn maybe we'll send
Wilson Rae a copy of essential as well
there's an essay about outcomes it's
called what is my outcome and it's not
that's another question I'm constantly
asking and I think it's really important
for you in terms of measuring it we hear
this term I especially used to hear it a
lot in the corporate world you can't
manage what you don't measure and well
that's that's somewhat true I I think
we're offering often measuring the wrong
things right we're measuring things that
are measurable and the problem with that
is it doesn't account for many of the
things that are are far more difficult
to describe the true successes in life
often can't be measured so a question
I'm asking all the time is
is my ideal outcome right and to get to
that outcome what do I need to do it
often people say they talk about the
goals they have but they don't
understand why they have those goals so
what is my outcome but then why is that
my outcome it's so much more important
to understand that why peace right
that's the benefit of the outcome it's
the what's the purpose behind this
outcome that we're working toward
together that gives you the leverage you
need to keep going quite often people
set goals for a family and a they
haven't talked to their family about the
goal but B they don't know why they're
doing what they're doing if you don't
know why you're doing what you're doing
hey you're gonna feel frustrated but B
you're probably not gonna have the
momentum you need to keep going when
times get tough so ask yourself why and
then it's also important as well as to
ask yourself is this working after
you've been taking action so so once
you've taken action toward toward that
outcome are those actions working or are
you just spinning your wheels and so as
you're working together as a family
these are some important questions to
ask and in fact I would encourage you to
constantly ask your kids questions and
also encourage your kids to ask
questions as well I think it's really
important and it's one of the things in
our culture that we quite often I know
the young kids they asked a ton of
questions there so exploratory and we
get frustrated by I know me personally I
get frustrated you're asking the same
question over and over but I also know
there'll be a point when Ella's 14 years
old
and I can't get her to ask me a single
question and and that will be that
that'll be difficult for a completely
different reason I'll be wanting her to
ask questions and so I think it's
important to encourage questions to be
asked because the better questions that
we ask and improving the type of
questions we ask the better answers
we're going to get and the more we're
going to grow together and so
encouraging questions in the family
constantly questioning even you is
important because it's going to by them
asking questions it also means that you
get to shape their worldview because
you're the one who's going to be
answering the most questions in their
life and so asking those questions
allows you to not just impose your
worldview on them but share your
worldview
open them up to your worldview your
belief your desires your values and be
able to communicate communicate those
effectively and also it's gonna help you
grow as well I know when Ella asked me
questions I don't have an answer to I
will often say I don't know because I
don't want to be dishonest with her but
then I try to figure out what the answer
is to that question and it helps me grow
in the process and it's certainly
helping her grow as well our next
question is from JD in North Carolina
I'm new to the whole minimalist thing
and I used to be a collector of several
things and regards to things of vanity
when something new came out I had to
have it tight situations in becoming a
minimalist or minimizing things how do
you govern it as a parent I always tell
people I'm better off because of what I
didn't have coming up so I try to give
my kids a desire to actually want for
something I think that creates some sort
of work effort I'm self-employed and I'm
a barber so I don't have so much time
sometimes there's limited a lot of times
my kids spend in the barber shop with me
and basically what I'm just looking for
is a focal point and how I could
transition from all of the debt I'm in
and still be a parent with kids JD I'm
glad you are new to minimalism welcome
aboard to the idea at least and you you
said a word there the word vanity you
are a former and an order collector to
the your former collector of vanity
items and that is a very honest
statement Bravo for for bringing that to
the forefront so if you look up
collector in a thesaurus you will often
find the word hoarder or the synonym for
the verb collect is hoard and so
collecting is well-planned hoarding in
many cases and when you talk about
vanity items
what does vanity vanity is a is a veneer
I'm trying to and I'm trying to impose a
I'm trying to project rather a facade or
an image of myself onto the world you
know so I don't know if it's you're
collecting air jordans or or jewelry
you know whatever baseball cards even I
mean it kind of depends on what what
you're trying to do now do I think all
collecting is inherently evil no I think
it's problematic most of the time in our
culture but if you get true joy from
collecting a bunch of Santa figurines at
Christmastime and displaying them
throughout the house great by all means
do that but the question is are they
actually I'd advise you life do they
really bring you joy and if not then
maybe your collection is actually
getting in the way for you because you
have to maintain the collection you have
to you know water the collection you
have to feed the collection you have to
clean the collection you have to dust
the collection you have to put oil in
the collection
whatever the thing may be they're
certainly taking care of it the actual
cost of a thing goes way beyond the
price tag especially if you're storing
the thing and and and it's taking up
space the these are all additional costs
that that are embedded in the thing that
are way beyond way beyond the price tag
and so you mentioned you grew up
relatively poor and you felt that you
were better off for what you didn't have
and you know what that really resonates
with me so I really poor back in Dayton
Ohio I was on government assistance and
WIC and food stamps and it was a
dysfunctional household before that term
dysfunctional was in vogue and and so
growing up I thought we were so
discontented because we didn't have a
lot of money and so when I left into the
corporate world in my late teens and
then climbed the corporate ladder
throughout my 20s I figured I could
become happy and and and content by
making more money the problem was it
wasn't the money it wasn't just the
money I should say that made us unhappy
it was a series of repeated bad
decisions throughout my childhood that
made us discontent the problem is as I
climbed the corporate ladder and made
good money that just enhanced the amount
of bad decisions I was able to make with
with good money and so of course I got
into debt I made really good money but
spent outrageous amounts of one
and got to a point where I had massive
amounts of debt six figures worth of
debt which you mentioned being in debt
JD and and because of that debt
I felt anchored I felt stressed out I
felt overwhelmed and minimalism was a
tool that I used to regain control of my
life and eventually over the course of
about four years work really hard to pay
off that debt and now I'm completely
debt-free and that that feels amazing
but it feels amazing because I'm making
better decisions with the resources I do
have and so whether you are young or old
rich or poor black or white wherever you
are on the socio-economic spectrum
minimalism is really about using the
resources we have
I was talking to Beck's about this last
night as she grew up at a completely
different background that they weren't
wealthy but they were certainly a middle
class or upper upper middle class and
she didn't want for anything growing up
but I think the reason that she had such
a good childhood that shaped her it was
for different reasons than the MA child
had shaped me by the way my childhood
was very difficult growing up and I
wouldn't want to ever go back to that
but did it shape me absolutely shave me
and made me a much stronger person but I
think the thing that the Bekaa had from
her her childhood was you she had
experiences that you couldn't replace
with material possessions and so when
you talk about not one thing from or we
talk about your kid your kids benefiting
from from desire yes I agree with that
in fact I think that we are what we
desire and so the question is how are we
going to instill in our kids the desire
for more meaningful experiences and so I
was talking to backup about this she was
talking about you know some of the
sports she was a soccer player and so
some of the most memorable times growing
up for the the team sports that she was
on or job she had which were difficult
you know she was literally shoveling
horse crap on a farm in in Minnesota
over the summer but that that helped
shape her character
in shape who she is today those
experiences and I think what what really
what we're talking about here what's the
correlation between her childhood and my
childhood is tension and resistance and
I think what you want to create for your
children whether or not they want it is
that we're all going to have once we're
all going to have desires you want to
create the right once the right desires
but you're also going to want to create
enough positive tension in their lives
enough positive resistance and I talked
earlier about discomfort when you get
into that area of discomfort that is the
area from which you are going to grow
and the same is obviously true for your
children and so they see you right now
by the way they they see you working
hard you know your barber and so you're
working in in a in a barber shop now and
sounds like they're they're hanging out
there and I think I think that's
important right because you're spending
time with them and they're going to be
mirroring your behaviors and so it's
really up to you to be your best self
when you're when you're in those moments
show them that you are entrepreneur and
and that you are you know while you're
far from perfect your being your best
self because if you settle if you settle
for less money or or less time with them
or whatever you're settling for they are
going to notice they're going to notice
if you're in debt even if you're not
constantly talking about it they're
gonna notice if you're stressed there
they're going to notice if you're
performing best at your your job they're
gonna notice the the things that you
bring into your life and the things that
you you bring in into their life so if
your best self because you're working on
a a passion project or you decide to
travel with the family once a year or
whatever it may be they are going to
notice that but they're also gonna
notice all the negative things too so
you want to strive to not be your
perfect self perfect is the enemy of
good or even of great you want to be
your great self flaws and all warts and
all you want to be there for them as
well and the other thing that I'll tell
you JD is I think it's also your job to
enjoy your kids and for me that that
that's been the biggest transition as
well is finding ways not to just tell
eight Ella you know who's a three year
old and has a bunch of kooky behaviors
but find ways to to enjoy her as a human
being and I think it is it is your job
first to enjoy them second it is your
job to raise them and and the reason I
think that's so important is if you
enjoy them they're going to see that joy
and they are going to mimic it they're
also going to enjoy their time with you
more and when you're enjoying them you
are sort of by proxy teaching them to
enjoy life and and I think that's an
important thing for you to remember and
I know earlier I mentioned my friend Rob
Bell he has talked about you don't treat
your kid as though they are a bucket in
which you pour your anxiety and and so I
think that's the opposite side of this
joy or enjoying your kids is as a parent
basically it's your job to try to work
through your own anxiety and not project
that on on to your kids and I know that
that's something that I certainly
struggle with it's easy for me to get
anxious especially when Ella is you're
screaming in the back seat or something
of the car but if I project that anxiety
onto her what's it going to do it's just
going to increase her level of anxiety
she knows when you're anxious and so we
need to be able to deal with that
without you know filling up their bucket
with with more anxiety another thing
that he says is give them as little as
possible that they'll have to unlearn
later as to think about that if you're
if you're teaching them you know the
ways of the world that are not congruent
with your best self you're gonna have to
try to get them to unlearn those
behaviors later and so the best thing to
do is try to get it right the first time
and if you don't get it right the second
time then the better the first time the
best thing is to get it right the second
time and not not perpetuate those those
negative behaviors and one last thing
that Rob Bell says that really resonates
with me is don't sacrifice your kids
thriving for your cowardice and
manure words have maybe never been
spoken but I think quite often we we
fear something and we don't want to have
our kids do do something and it's just
because we're scared and when our our
fear stunts our kids growth that is man
that that's so difficult because we're
gonna have to deal with it and then of
course have them unlearn that later and
so I know one thing that you're
certainly afraid about JD is debt and
believe me I can understand why debt is
one of the biggest anchors and I think
it keeps us from feeling free and we
don't feel free we certainly feel an
amount of anxiety and fear and stress we
feel overwhelmed and so JD I'd love to
send you a copy of our book essential
it's an essay collection has a 150
essays in it but there's an entire
chapter on finances in there that I
think it'll really help you out there's
an essay in there called financial
freedom five difficult steps to get out
of debt and I actually put a version of
that essay on our website as well so
other folks can check that out just over
at the minimalists comm slash freedom
and I really mean that it's five
difficult steps to get out of debt
because getting out of debt isn't easy
but it's so worth it because especially
for your kids you want to create a life
for them to where they don't they don't
see that debt and you don't want them to
get into that same situation so we'll
either send you a print version of that
book or ebook version or it just came
out on audiobook as well so Sean if you
have any audible download codes left if
you could send JD either the audiobook
if you wants to listen to that there or
the the print or ebook versions those
are available as well we'll get that out
to you there's also an essay in there
that I that I really love it's called
eleven signed you might be broke and it
really goes to show that we are all
we've all been broke at some point or at
least broke in and and and talking about
getting out of being broke in our own
lives and by the way I don't mean just
financially that's that's one small
sliver of being broke
and yeah well I'd love to hear what
everyone else has to hear right because
I need I need the parenting advice as
well so if you have a comment about
parenting including minimalism tips or
just parenting tips in general about how
you handle your kids then leave us a
voicemail 406 to 1 9 7 8 3 9 we will air
our favorite comments and tips on the
next episode and here's a tip for you
make sure you write down your message
before you call in it will help you
articulate your point and it will
increase your chance of being on the
podcast ok let's move on
real quick to our hashtag ask the
minimalists lightning-round this is
where we answer questions from social
media and when I say we I mean I because
I wish Ryan was here I know all of you
you miss Ryan you want him on the
podcast I want in here too
they go much better when we're having
good conversations together but he will
be back on the next episode so so don't
worry
but we're on Twitter and Instagram at
the minimalists and facebook.com slash
the minimalists and during the lightning
round
this will Ryan and I typically answer
each question was just a short shareable
less than 140 character response and
then we put the text to these minimal
Maxim's so we call them minimal Maxim's
in the show notes so you can copy and
paste our pithy answers on social media
if you'd like so our first question let
me pull up my document here our first
question is from Eric Eric asks how do I
get my kids crap in check they don't
want to let go of anything and my pithy
answer to this is before we let go we
should first understand the benefits and
so I know I already talked about this a
bit so I won't elaborate too much Eric
but you got to figure out what the
benefits are for your kids if you want
them to let go what are the benefits of
letting go too often we illustrate the
actions but we don't illustrate the
purpose and I think that's good by the
way to illustrate the actions but you
want to praise their actions
instead of praising their features and
this is one thing that that I deal with
all the time you know it's weird because
we often tell our kids all you're so
pretty or you look elder gets it all the
time we're at the grocery store or
something oh is she cute as if she has
anything to do with being cute it's like
I'm so proud you never hear me say I'm
so proud you have brown eyes Ola but I
am going to acknowledge her actions when
she does something I really like I will
stop I will pause and I say I really
like how you did that that is great and
when she does something wrong I found
that I've shifted over the last year or
so I found my initial reaction was
something like why are you doing that or
just stop what are you doing and that
doesn't work but that that's me
questioning who she is as a person and
and her as opposed to commenting on her
actual behavior her action if I don't
like something she's doing quite often
I'll say that's not what we do that's
not what we do in this household and I
will even say I don't like when you do
this and be very specific about it and
that's not what we do I think that's
more empowering and because then I can't
explain here's how we do behave and and
that's far more important and then when
we're talking about here's how we do
behave we need to explain why and kids
always want to know why for sure but the
Y is really the benefit behind those
behaviors so if your kids can't let go
of anything Erik help them understand
why it's important for them to let go
and remember the benefits for them are
different from the benefits for you
alright next question is from Erin on
Twitter she asks my sister needs help
with minimalist travel with children
they have so many accessories okay
well here's my short tweetable answer I
think it was exactly 140 characters when
traveling limit yourself to what fits in
only one bag sometimes limitations are
freeing they force you to select only
the essentials I think that's nice I do
that with creativity sometimes so if I'm
writing I will often limit myself
to a timeframe or amount of words and
and I call creative limitations although
we were supposed to leave for Florida a
few days ago and before that flight got
canceled and we were headed down there
and Beck said her one carry-on piece of
luggage packed and so like a little tiny
suitcase that fits into the overhead bin
on an airplane and she had one side
completely full of her clothes and stuff
she needs for for travel in fact I think
you she's here right now did you read a
blog post about you about travel right
yeah so so you can on her on her blog
minimal wellness comm a slash travel she
writes about you know traveling lately
and so she had half of the suitcase
empty and Ella walks past the suitcase
and says is this my half of the suitcase
and because she knows that her mom packs
everything for both of them in one
carry-on suitcase now does that mean
that we can carry though everything in
the house no that's not the point of
traveling though you want to bring only
the essentials and sometimes these
limitations will force you to bring only
the essentials another thing I'll do
when we're traveling with Ella she
travels with her little backpack that
she has with her and quite often she'll
want to fill it up before we leave so
she has this little tiny backpack but I
will never ever carry that backpack for
her it is up to her to everything that
she has picked up she has to carry and I
mean that both literally and
metaphorically anything that your kids
pick up they should also be willing to
carry that and it's quite the lesson if
it's something that's too heavy for them
and so yeah I would keep that in mind
when you're traveling I think sometimes
these limitations they help you enjoy
the experience a lot more because you're
not lugging around a bunch of stuff if
you have two people if you have backs
and Ella who have everything in this one
piece of luggage just one suitcase that
fits an overhead bin you have far less
stuff to worry about it doesn't mean you
can't pack as many accessories yes but
you can pack the most essential ones and
it's going to help you really determine
what is truly essential all right Mimi
asks how can I get my kids to understand
that time is the greatest gift
regardless of what commercials say well
I'm gonna go back one more time to rob
Bell I love this quote from him he says
you were always teaching your kids and
sometimes you use words you are always
teaching your kids and sometimes you use
words so keep that in mind quite often
the consumeristic behaviors that kids
pick up they pick up directly from their
parents and so the way to break that
cycle is for us to break the cycle first
and for us not to react to those
commercials and for us to bring fewer
advertisements into our lives it's the
reason we don't do advertisements on
this podcast it costs us a lot of money
we have many people who want to
advertise in this podcast but we refuse
every time and the reason being is it
doesn't align with my values it doesn't
align with the best version of myself it
doesn't align with the best version of
Ryan and so we refuse to do it instead
we find other ways to to earn an income
and those ways always have to align with
the best version of me I'm not allergic
to making money but I am allergic to not
behaving in a way that is congruent with
the person I want to be and so keep that
in mind
align find ways to align your short-term
actions with your long-term values and
and of course your kids will mirror that
they will follow all right finally
Michael asks how can I help my kids
manage the fact that social status at
school is often tied to material
possessions alright my short answer on
this one is my tweetable answer is you
don't have to try to be better than
anyone to be a better human being
now instilling that in your kids is
obviously going to be a bit more
difficult so so let's go back to
outcomes for a minute you want to ask
you kids what what outcome are they
trying to achieve here by by material
possessions by the way let's put let's
put this out here right away
material possessions aren't inherently
bad I have clothes on right now I own
material possessions we all need some
stuff I am
against consumption I'm against
compulsory consumption I'm against
impulsive consumption I'm against
compulsive a consumption
I'm not against consumption in fact the
weird paradox of minimalism is as a
minimalist I get far more value from the
things I own today then if they were
watered down by 300,000 items that I
used to own because I own so much stuff
I didn't know what was actually adding
value to my life but now I know that
everything I own
serves a purpose in my life where it
brings me joy I truly get value from the
things I own and so asking your kids how
does this add value to your life and
then what is your outcome if your
outcome is is social status then why do
they want that what's the why behind
that well the why is because I want to
be liked okay I mean that's generally
the why behind social status or
significant significance is a big why
it's a big why for me for sure I
certainly want to feel significant
especially with the people in my inner
circle the people I care about most and
so how can I add value to their lives so
I do feel significant what's the
positive way that I can fulfill that
significant or set another way what
other paths
besides material possessions can I take
to get that to that outcome how else can
I be significant in a positive way
because we all have a need a need for
significance and we can either fulfill
that need negatively you know if I
threatened someone threatened to beat
someone up who is less powerful than me
then of course I'm going to get
significance from that person but it's
not the good kind of significant
significance through fear as opposed to
significance through value if I
contribute to someone's life and they're
grateful for that well then I feel
significant for all the right reasons
and so how can you help them feel
significant for the right reasons how
can you help them get to that outcome
besides material possessions those
material possessions sure they can help
augment their high school experience but
they don't have to drive their high
school experience it's the same thing
that I talked about a second ago with
with advertisements or with money
I'm okay with making money it's just no
longer the primary driver for doing
what I do and it's it's fine to earn an
income it's fine to have social status
the question is is it driving your
behavior and if so then maybe we can
change that maybe we can find a
different outcome and then I also saw a
bunch of questions on Instagram people
are asking about nighttime asleep
routines with with kids I try to have as
few things in the routine as possible
that makes the the routine relatively
easy we don't have a specific time that
ela goes to bail it tends to be around 7
or 8 or sometimes 9 o'clock somewhere
between there and it's not about having
a specific time necessarily in fact it
tends to be earlier in the winter and in
Missoula Montana it gets dark around
4:30 in the winter so it tends to be
earlier yeah Ella's already commenting
at 5 p.m. that sure is dark outside it's
almost time for bed because she has that
behavior we like to read before bed and
obviously there's bath time and there is
teeth brushing and some pretty simple
hygiene routines and then reading before
bed and I think those are the the main
things that we do to try to create a a
calm place for her but also if we're
traveling somewhere we want to have
fewer routines so that it is easier to
get to bed elsewhere and it was harder
for kids when they're traveling to go to
sleep generally and so if you have just
some triggers if and sometimes that's
that's bath time that triggers the
entire evening routine and then brushing
your teeth and then reading some stories
and then it's time to go to bed and and
and that is a simple nighttime routine
also try not to eat too too soon before
going to bed I think it's just good for
for all of us because digestion tends to
keep us up a bit later than then we
would like quite often all right well
it's time to move on to our added-value
portion of the show this is where we get
to recommend something that has added
value to our lives recently and since
we're talking about parenting today I
have two things for you
first off I have mentioned rob bell
several times throughout this episode he
has an audio book that belongs to a book
that doesn't exist I'll try to explain
that here in a second but it's called
launching rockets and it is just this
great audio program Becca and I listened
to it on a long drive out to Seattle
once we were we were driving out there
and so Rob and his wife Kristin who were
just great people he wrote down these 17
observations that he has about parenting
and about about his children in
particular and and questions that he's
been asked over the years on different
tour stops and on book tours and things
like that and these 17 beautiful
succinct observations and it's about
three hours long it's just this audio
it's almost like a pod calf podcast half
audio book it's just him riffing for two
hours straight about these 17
observations that he has written down
and then during the last hour he brings
his wife Kristen in and that she gives
her observations on his observations I
think a lot of you will find a lot of
value on that I'll put a link to that in
the show notes I think it's on his
website but you'll be able to find that
there in our show notes at the
minimalists comm a slash podcast and
also if you're listening for another
podcast I get a lot of parenting advice
and I've learned so much from a podcast
called mom and dad are fighting and it's
from Slate and they have a lot of good
advice a lot a lot of tips a lot of
successes and failures that they talk
about and I know I've recommended this
one before but it's the perfect
recommendation for for this podcast so
mom and dad are fighting we'll put a
link to that in the show notes as well
all right let's move on to right here
right now that's where we finally start
talking about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalists as I mentioned
Ryan is down in Florida right now we
have a coffee shop down there called
bandit you can take a photo tour of that
coffee shop over at the minimalists comm
slash coffee house we were doing some
upgrades to the coffee house this month
we're doing some new furniture and mural
outside of the shop it's
just a really well-crafted well curated
community space that we helped create
there in st. Petersburg Florida with our
good friends Joshua and Sarah Weaver
they're the proprietors of the shop that
they're the the the brain trust behind
the whole operation and they reached out
to us for some help and starting this
about a year ago and we're really proud
to bring that to everyone so Ryan's down
there right now I wish I was there but
I'm not because of canceled flight but
that's okay during the holidays our
documentary is now out on Netflix so if
you haven't had a chance to watch
minimalism a documentary about the
important things you can gather some
friends around fire up Netflix and and
watch watch this documentary with your
friends and family start some good
discussions online share it with your
friends and family online as well if you
don't have Netflix don't worry it's also
available on itunes google play amazon
and it's on vimeo all and that's with
the six hours of bonus content on vimeo
which you can just watch that bonus
content by itself on vimeo if you've
already watched the film on netflix and
if you watch the film watch movies the
old-school way if you're still going to
the red boxes or the the 14 blockbuster
videos that are still in business did
you know there's still 14 blockbusters
that are in business most of them are in
alaska and texas and the back is
pointing at me right now actually
remembers blockbusters and and she lived
in Alaska for a while but yes
blockbuster is still around but I don't
think our DVD is that blockbuster but
you can find it over at minimalism
film.com
and by the way 2017 we're potentially
going to do a tour Ryan and I are
working on these these six simple ideas
and we want to do a different kind of
tour we want to do some intimate crowds
so our last few tours are like our tour
in 2014 we had 75,000 people come out to
a hundred different tour stops we want
to do much more intimate crowds this
time so we're gonna we're going to rent
out some small theater spaces or art
galleries and bring these simple ideas
and try them out in front of these small
audiences we're going to announce that
over at the
let's calm over but but what you should
do if you want to be if you want to be
the first to know because I'm sure
tickets to those will go pretty quickly
you'll just get on our email newsletter
list so go to the minimalists comm type
in your email we'll never ever send you
spam because we think spam is disgusting
we'll never do pop-up ads will never do
advertisements but we will keep you up
to date of any tour stops we're going to
do so if you put your email and over
there that is what is going on right
here right now with the minimalists
alright finally here are some voicemail
comments and tips from our listeners hi
my name is Karissa hipster I'm from
Columbus Ohio this year instead of
buying gifts for one another my family
has decided to sponsor a refugee family
coming in to Ohio and buy them
everything they've needed for their home
it's been a great way to replace just
kind of pointless consumerism that we've
had before in the past and our family
and it's given a new family in this area
a wonderful start to their life here in
Ohio it's been a great experience and I
think it's a new tradition that will
continue for years to come this is
Kaitlin calling from Baltimore Maryland
I wanted to share minimalism tip which
is to pick a brand this might encounter
to do is to minimalism and supportive of
consumerism but let me explain so say
you've recently outgrown your favorite
winter coat and you decide to donate it
and use by anyone but you missed your
favorite coat it was exactly what you
needed no more and no less so you decide
to prove the malls department stores
online retailers local shops looking for
your new favorite coat you've spent
hours days and weeks now looking for
your new favorite coat and still have
nothing so here's my solution pick a
brand soror retailer as your go-to for
all items you need in your life so you
might have a go-to for your clothes you
might have a go-to for your kitchen
wares and appliances you might have a
go-to for miscellaneous things like
toiletries household items you can make
standards for these go
so for example I use Patagonia for all
my outdoor clothes because they're
environmentally and socially conscious
and I use everlean for all of my casual
and work clothes because they're known
for Fairtrade and ethical practices so
maybe your standards of your brands are
that they're quick and easy to access or
that they look cool or that they have
organic products whatever your standards
are but the idea is that you kind of
pick your go-to and you set your
standards and you stick to them so just
yesterday I could have spent time
billing from Michael's to Hobby Lobby to
jo-ann fabrics because I was looking for
gift wrap and I thought oh maybe these
different stores have different types of
wrap I should check them all out but I
just remember just take a brand and I
use Target whenever I have miscellaneous
things like toiletries or stationery or
things like that and so I just went to
Target and I got that done within you
know ten minutes so picking a brand can
help you reduce your decision fatigue
and it reduces the amount of time that
you're shopping in brausen and makes
more time for the things that really
matter
hi I'm Paul Busch I live in Moscow Idaho
I'm an Idaho College student and
minimalist this calls mostly about my
mom though she's always struggled
financially and views my desire for less
with defensive Nosara doing about my
choices when I returned home for the
holidays this year she said what do you
want for Christmas I won't take nothing
as an answer well I took your guys
advice and I sent her a link to the UN's
refugee nonprofit and later that day I
received a notification that she had
donated with a message that said Merry
Christmas and it was really cool it was
really great that she could fulfill her
need to give something to me through
something that I wouldn't just reduced
or throw away all right job
another something completely different
hello everyone my name is Joshua fields
Milburn and we are on Twitter live my
guess is this is like periscope but on
Twitter or may even be on periscope but
I wanted to do just a really quick
session of ask the minimalist I just
finished recording a parenting podcast
so some of you got to see parts of that
live but the Twitter stream gave out on
me and so let's let's dive back into
this just for a second and Shawn will be
able to pin this part somewhere toward
the end here alright everyone we are
back just a few more observations for
you now that I've answered a bunch of
questions on this podcast I wanted to
tune back in for a second I am I'm on
Twitter alive right now answering a few
questions but I know we have some from
Instagram as well so my partner Bex is
is over there on the other side of the
room maybe she can she can throw a few
questions out for me and I'll repeat
them into the microphone and we can we
can talk about those questions there
were some good ones that you brought up
a moment ago okay kids and and gifts
yeah a lot of people are asking about
gifts for this this holiday time of year
and instead of rehashing everything that
I've talked about regarding gift-giving
over the last three or four weeks I'm
going to point you in two directions one
is Ryan and I did an entire podcast
about gift-giving
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes to this episode but I believe it
was episode number 38 if I'm not
mistaken you can go back into our
archives at the minimalists comm slash
podcast and there is probably an
hour-and-a-half riff on gift-giving
especially with kids and how we handle
gifts with with or how I handle gifts
with Ella and with the people I care
about most of my life as well so check
out that podcast episode if you're
interested in gift-giving with kids we
had one about sort of sentimental items
and maybe I can just touch on and I'll
try to summarize the
we had a woman on Instagram if you want
to follow us on Instagram by the way
we're at the minimalists on Instagram
pretty easy to to find us pretty much
anywhere on the socials but uh she was
asking in her question about how do I
let go of all these sentimental items
I'm finding it really difficult I find
it so difficult to let go of old clothes
that she wore because all of these
memories and all of the artwork that was
drawn because there's so many memories
how can I let go of this and I've built
up this attachment the sentimentality is
attachment via sentimentality to all of
these these material possessions and I
totally relate to them what I'll tell
you though and this is a lesson I
learned early on when right before I was
right as I was bracing minimalism
bracing minimalism by the way my my
mother died right before I found
minimalism
and the first my first foray into to
letting go of stuff was letting go of
some very difficult sentimental items
and she was down in Saint Petersburg
Florida and I had to go deal with her
stuff after she passed away and it was
an incredibly difficult time for me but
as I was letting go the stuff I learned
a bunch of important lessons I think the
most important lesson I learned though
is about our memories our memories
aren't in our things our memories are
inside us and I think they always will
be inside us it I think it's nice that
sometimes the things that we have can
trigger the memories that are inside us
but the memories don't rest in those
things so if you keep the kids clothes
boxed up in an attic or in a bin in the
basement or stuffed into a closet
somewhere and the same goes with the
artwork or anything else if you're
holding on to these things because you
think you're holding on to memories just
know that the memories aren't aren't in
those boxes the memories are in you and
if you need some triggers to help you
trigger those memories that are inside
you one of the things I did with my
mom's stuff and things that all
something I'll do with some of the Hello
stuff from time to time is take a
picture of the stuff because those
pictures can trigger those same exact
memories so if I need the thing I need
to have access to the thing that
triggered the memory I have access to
the photo and the same goes with artwork
or with photograph
in general I find it much more
empowering to scan those and have those
backed up in the cloud somewhere because
think about this you're holding on to
all this artwork right you think you're
you're holding on to two old photographs
or old paintings old drawings whatever
you're holding on to and and what
happens if you have a fire or a flood
those things are gone forever right now
it wouldn't be the end of the world if
those things were gone forever it
probably wouldn't really make a big
difference but if you want access to
those things then the most responsible
thing to do is to scan those items now
you can take a look at the actual
scanner that I I use to scan photographs
and paper work etc tax documents
whatever over at the minimalists comm a
/ scanning I did something called
a scanning party and I just did that
because if you put party at the end of
anything ryan shows up and so he had a
packing party I had a scanning party and
we will constantly do things that are
not very fun I just put the end put the
word party at the end of it and he'll be
there so have your own scanning party
and you actually can make it a little
bit more fun by bringing some friends
over and scanning photographs scanning
the artwork and talking having
conversations about those things and
scanning the other people's stuff as
well share your scanner yeah Ryan and I
share a scanner now and so but by us
sitting down and scanning different
things we get to have conversations
about those photographs and no longer
are they occupying you know a corner and
the basement somewhere I was able to let
go of the physical artifacts because I
knew I was not letting go of the
memories I saw the memory that the
memories inside me I saw the triggers to
those memories I was letting go of the
stuff not the memories we have one or
two more questions
[Music]
okay so this person yeah this person
wants to know about I'm considering
holding on to the clothes and toys and
material possessions from from my
current child who's growing up for a
potential child in the future my answer
to you would be if you're certain you're
gonna have a second kid and it makes
sense for you to hold on to some of the
stuff then that's that's fine if you're
uncertain which this person is I would
strongly encourage you to to let go of
the stuff because I don't like holding
on to just in case items yeah if you
know me you know I think the three most
dangerous words in the English language
are just in case and that goes for our
kids stuff as well because letting go of
those items will allow you to add value
to someone else's life instead of
hoarding them in your basement or
somewhere in a storage locker on the
edge of town for 10 years you can
actually pass those on to someone else
who can get value from them and then by
the way you can also get hand-me-downs
from someone else in the future as well
if you've established some relationships
with other parents in your community
it'll actually be relatively easy for
you to get some hand-me-down items in
the future if and it's a big if for you
you're not sure if you're gonna have
another kid it's a big if if you're
going to hold on to those things just in
case now if you know if you're certain
you're gonna have a another kid you want
to pass it on then you're not holding on
to these things just in case you're
holding on to them at just for when and
even in that scenario I would encourage
you to radically downsize I would
encourage you to to let go of many of
the the items that that you're holding
on to that you think you need
someday in some hypothetical future as
opposed to what you're actually going to
need to hold on to all right let's do
one more on this this special LIVE
lightning round you got one more for us
backs
or how do you explain to your child
okay so so if and I'm certainly in the
situation I'll repeat the question here
real quick if you are are in a household
that has a divided household so to speak
you have you have two parents who are no
longer together and then you have a new
partner or new spouse and with a certain
different belief template between
between those two households how do you
communicate to the kid that the two sets
of parents have different beliefs and I
one that stands out to me right away is
Santa Claus like I clearly don't believe
in Santa Claus and I think that it's a
lie to tell Ella that Santa Claus exists
even though she thinks she does because
she saw Santa Claus at the mall recently
and I had to explain to her that Santa
Claus is a man who is dressed up like
Santa Claus and it's okay to believe in
him as an imaginary figure and I the the
illustration that I used to explain
Santa Claus to her was she loves
watching this cartoon this British
cartoon called Peppa Pig and clearly she
doesn't believe those are real people
she knows that those are made-up
characters and that if I were to put a
Peppa Pig costume on I wouldn't become
Peppa Pig I would just be a imaginary
character I'd be dressed up as an
imaginary character and Santa Claus is
it is the same thing so I'm not going to
tell her I'm not going to lie to her but
at the same time I don't want her to be
I don't want her to be the kid who goes
around you know telling kids that Santa
isn't real and it's not her position to
rain on everyone else's parade either
and so the her father and I may have
different beliefs about about many
different things and I think I think the
key here is to just be open and honest
with her and and to communicate with her
even even though she's three years old
to find ways to communicate with with
Ella effectively that explained to her
why I do what I do and and it's the
other parents job to explain why they do
what they do and the only thing that I
can do is put my best foot forward and
the scenario and and and try really hard
to explain what my values are what my
beliefs are but in a way that's not
esoteric or erudite in a way that she
can understand and and the the best way
to do that is through through my actions
and through being willing to talk to her
when she has questions about something
like Santa Claus or or about rituals or
traditions that we have because let's
face it we all have different traditions
even if they are similar traditions and
many of us like celebrate Christmas but
some of us celebrate like me I celebrate
in a secular sense not in their
religious context many people will
celebrate Kris the same thing they
celebrate Christmas in a in a religious
context and and that's okay we're
effectively celebrating the same holiday
before completely to two completely
different belief templates and so we get
to that same thing via different paths
and the best thing that I can do is is
articulate my path to did to that ritual
or to that tradition to that that
holiday experience and it's not up to me
to articulate everyone else's path I can
do my best to to be open and honest
about my thoughts about those things but
also I want to be very careful not to
denigrate other people's beliefs and in
front of her especially people that she
cares about and so it's not my position
to knock someone else's belief template
it's it's my position when she asked
questions to instill what I believe and
in her and and I think we'll leave it at
that that's a good place to in this
episode Sean I don't know where we're
going to post this in in the episode
itself I want to say hello to everyone
out here on Twitter we're trying out
Twitter live for the first time now and
so I'm gonna sign out from the podcast
and I'm also gonna sign out from this
Twitter livestream thanks for joining me
oh by the way if you all haven't seen it
yet our documentary minimalism a
documentary about the important things
is now on Netflix I would be very
grateful if you left at a five star
review if you found value in that film
if you don't have Netflix you can find
it anywhere else
all the links are over at minimalism
Phil
dot-com hope you find value in that
we'll see you next time until then love
people use things opposite never ever
works we'll see you next time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
every little thing that you got Han
every little thing that you got you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine
without your team
[Music]
you
[Music]